(old band music)
- Oh God. (laughs)
- Okay, uhhh.
- Wow, I've never seen those giant
Starbucks bags.
- Yeah.
Alright, holy, oh my God.
- Oh no.
- Oh my Ga...
- It's mostly drinks,
I don't see any food.
- Yeah, that's
oh my God.
- Okay, there we go.
There's the food.
No it's more drinks.
Well, I can
oh there's more!
- Well...
(laughing)
- What the?
- Can I Instagram this real quick?
- Yeah, me too.
Even if we could drink all of this
we would probably get
a heart attack and die.
(laughing)
- This looks like something I would drink.
- [Evan] I don't know what this is.
- Oh.
My favorite drink, cheers.
Cheers, shots.
- Why does it feel like I'm pre-gaming?
- Oh God.
(band music)
Let's try the next one.
- Help.
I don't know if I can continue this.
- Creamy.
- I'm lightheaded.
- Finished another box you guys.
We're almost halfway done.
- Halfway?
- Well, I think we got more,
actually we have more food.
Well that looks good.
- [Evan] Oh is that beef?
- I've never seen these on the menu.
- Oh this looks good.
And they got onions too, what?
We drank like, like
I'm sure,
- Almost half of those.
- I'm positive we drank like all of this.
- We only have sweets left for food now.
I think I have better
tolerance for sweets than you.
- It's not because I'm full, it's because
I'm just really sugar high right now.
- So?
Get higher.
- How are you feeling right now?
- Happy.
- Oh this is sausage.
This is the sausage one.
- Oh, I don't like sausage that much.
- You don't like it?
- I don't like the flat sausages.
That's what she said.
- This is hard.
This is harder than I thought.
I'm sweating.
The drinks are starting to
all taste like cinnamon.
- I'm hot.
(laughing)
We're almost there.
- We're down to our last tray.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, hot.
- Last drink.
- Oh my God.
That was a lot of caffeine,
a lot of sugar.
- Sugar,
I'm just really, really
sugar high right now.
- My hands very shakey.
- Yeah.
Sure.
Oh!
- Oh my goodness.
It could be a scarf.
(laughing)
well, um...
- Well it's time to share.
- I don't even care, I
just want to drink it.
- [YB] I don't even know what they are.
Gonna drop off this beer to
say thank you to the employees
at Starbucks who made
all those drinks for us.
(old band music)
- [YB] Would you like a little pick-me-up?